[Musique]
nous avons un site ici près de
versailles parmi l ensemble des sites
que nous avons en france
ce site est dédié à la purification de
l'eau des systèmes confus par les 250
collaborateurs que nous avons sur ce
site
ces outils sont utilisés pour des
objectifs académiques de la recherche et
dans l'industrie pharmaceutique ne parle
pas de ces sites est important pour
notre activité en france mais aussi pour
une autre activité à l'international
dans notre activité sciences de la vie
l'un des services que nous rendons c'est
la purification de l'eau narrateur et
ses sites contribuent à servir nos
clients sur ce segment d'activité
[Musique]
oui nous allons continuer à développer
ce business sur le long terme et nous
sommes ravis des performances de ces
sites